call me dude Z this movie was uh hard to
watch and I will say these actresses
that are in it you got Sally Fields you
got Legend all Fonda all Legend Lily
Tomlin yeah Rita Moreno all legends all
fantastic and not one of them
could make me believe they gave a
about football or Tom Brady and it's a
no offense to them it's not their fault
this is a hard thing to do I
feel like the whole premise of the movie
was just like I'm watching it the whole
time and I'm like do you like the NFL
yeah then do you want to see four 80
year old women going to the Super Bowl
no do you are you an 80 year old woman
who wants to watch a movie about a fun
adventure between 80 year old women
friends yeah how about that Adventures
going to the Super Bowl oh no then I
don't want to see it they take both
potential audiences and say you I
mean it's in the premise of it I think
it's like a lot of God Rest his soul
Gary Marshall's later works it's the
fart fumes of pretty lady